o
[Música]
liberdade liberdade um dos valores
humanos que mais buscamos agir livre
arbítrio com vontade própria sem
prejudicar ninguém é poder viver a vida
que a gente sonha trabalhar aquilo que a
gente chama naquilo que a gente acredita
quando a gente entende que resgatar o
humano é ter a liberdade de poder olhar
para o seu passado vislumbrar o futuro
de orgulho e poder de escolha a partir
disso eu vejo que como mulher negra não
é tão simples chegar nesse lugar
eu passei a minha infância
acreditando que fosse possível ter um
futuro promissor por conta do meu
talento
eu sempre amei desenhar e até hoje nutre
uma paixão pela arquitetura pela
animação e pela ilustração
eu sempre achei que isso fosse possível
porque fazia parte das minhas raízes
criativas da minha família eu sempre
vivi em volta da minha mãe e das minhas
tias nos seus trabalhos com a costura
com as artes e com a educação
mas eu não enxergava até chegar na sala
de aula que a minha cor fosse um
impeditivo para que os meus talentos
viessem à tona
eu sentir na sala de aula o preconceito
eo racismo em pequenas atitudes e muitos
casos eu era a única negra na sala de
aula
convivendo com apelidos constrangedores
e com a solidão
tudo isso rodando a minha autoestima
a minha vontade de sonhar e de expressar
as minhas ideias e nisso eu comecei
então
dentro dessa jornada na escola a ver que
a forma como eu me apresentava para as
pessoas se refletir também no meu cabelo
como para toda menina e mulher negra o
grande desafio na época era o cabelo
porque o melhor cabelo era o cabelo liso
ou cabelo amarrado porque de outro jeito
ele era visto como sujo não era o cabelo
mais bonito ou apropriado
afinal não tinha nada nas minhas bonecas
ou na tv que me dissesse o contrário
e então depois de adulta
depois de passar por um longo e doloroso
processo de transição capilar
eu finalmente consegui soltar meu cabelo
mostrando assim a minha real identidade
só que eu sempre achei que esse processo
ele fosse solitário mas ele era mais
comum do que eu imaginava
por conta da internet eu passei a
conhecer outras mulheres que também
passaram por essa jornada que para
muitas eram uma jornada de
autoconhecimento de resgate de batalha
contra crenças limitantes iguais às
minhas
porém o cabelo ele é só um detalhe
escondido atrás das oportunidades
quando a gente fala então de de
oportunidades
eu então ao longo dessa jornada eu
acabei deixando o sonho da arquitetura e
da animação porque eram faculdades caras
na época e tive que descobrir outras
formas de explorar aquilo que eu amava e
então eu tive a sorte do design do
digital me encontrarem e se tornarem a
minha paixão até então foi neles que
trabalhou em agências de comunicação e
de publicidade e que desabrochei para o
empreendedorismo onde hoje atuo e tenho
a possibilidade de desenhar na jornada
da minha carreira da forma como eu
quiser escolher
porém a gente vê e vive é vendido pra
nós que é o que o empreendedorismo é o
glamour de ter ideias de ser próximo
steve jobs de ter um grande negócio de
ganhar muito dinheiro
só que não é foi isso empreendedorismo
que eu vivi não é a realidade de muitos
empreendedores e empreendedoras negras
agente empreende por necessidade para
sobreviver
nisso eu lembro das histórias da minha
mãe já falecida que quando nós morávamos
em dom pedrito no interior do rio grande
do sul ela costureira e estilista abriu
três lojas de moda por lá
as três fracassaram muito porque a gente
não tinha acesso à educação
empreendedora a recursos a maior
conhecimento em gestão em finanças
quantos não ficaram devendo pra ela o
quanto as noites ela trabalhou horas e
horas para desenvolveu uma coleção um
desfile
só que agora empreendendo e trabalhando
também com a educação empreendedora eu
vejo que a realidade da minha mãe de
empreender por necessidade
ela é real no brasil hoje disse hoje 17
por cento dos empreendedores no país são
mulheres negras sendo que 49% empreendem
por necessidade muito da dessa
necessidade vem inclusive por conta de
não encontrar um emprego e entre os
muitos motivos estão desde serem mães
solos e não conseguirem dividiria essa
jornada dupla muitas vezes de trabalho
ou ainda pelo próprio preconceito contra
o cabelo crespo a área de negócios com
maior atuação
empreendedora é em serviços domésticos
com 18%
ainda vemos poucas de nós no design na
inovação e na tecnologia
quantas vezes eu já fui em eventos essas
áreas e olhava para o lado e não
enxergava nenhuma mulher negra
já no entre intra-empreendedorismo esse
cenário é ainda mais gritante das 500
maiores empresas no brasil hoje 1,6 por
cento de mulheres negras estão em cargos
de gerência e pasme 0,4 são se ouço ou
seja apenas duas mulheres
tudo isso em um país onde 28% da
população é composta por nós mulheres
negras são o maior grupo populacional do
brasil segundo o ibge
isso mostra o quão desigual nós somos
quantas oportunidades estão sendo
perdidas
quantos talentos estão sendo
desperdiçados porque se eu tive o
privilégio de ter uma família que me
apoiasse que me dessem suporte para que
eu pudesse trilhar minha carreira
enquanto o designer e empreendedora
conta as mulheres negras estão sem essa
chance e eu falo desse recorte porque
vivo e sinto isso
mas quantas minorias estão sendo
inviabilizados por conta da falta de
oportunidades e de liberdade
existe uma falácia é muito grande quando
tocamos no assunto de diversidade é
melhor a gente não conversar sobre isso
é melhor negar que ela existe
um dia quem sabe ela desaparece
enquanto ela não dói em mim ela não é
urgente
se ela não faz parte do meu dia a dia
ela vai se resolver passar quem sabe mas
na verdade diversidade é sobre a
pluralidade de culturas de linguagens de
raças e etnias de idades de gêneros e de
condições diferentes das suas
e aí está a riqueza
então quando falamos de diversidade
estamos falando de criar novas
oportunidades de dar novas
possibilidades a uma parcela da
população que está desassistida
eu faço parte do maior grupo
populacional do brasil que consome 16
por cento em produtos e serviços e gera
700 bilhões de reais em receita às
empresas mais lucrativas do mundo já
possuem programas de liderança e de
desenvolvimento para fomentar cada vez
mais equipes com pluralidade na sua
comunicação na sua estratégia enquanto
essência de marca
então estamos falando de um de verdade
tirar a a adversidade do discurso e
torná la uma ação de abraçar a inclusão
de fato e para tornar uma de adversidade
uma ação o primeiro passo é se tornar
consciente de que o problema existe
ele está aqui e não podemos ignorá lo é
ouvir ser empático de verdade
ouvindo escutando ativamente as
minorias é ser agente da mudança
comprando de empreendedores negros de
mulheres de lgbts de pessoas com
deficiência é criar pontes não só com as
pessoas que estão sendo inviabilizados
conversando com elas mas também criando
de algo com quem não tem não conhece
sobre essas realidades e dar luz a isso
é criar também oportunidades onde você
está incentivando apoiando e mentor ando
pessoas que não necessariamente têm a
mesma sorte que você e acima de tudo é
importante também que não se trata
apenas um negro ou a minoria como ator
figurativo e sim permita que ele seja
voz ativa com proporcionalidade nos
espaços de fala empatia é um exercício
diário ela num acaba quando você acha
que o preconceito morreu dentro de você
o preconceito jamais vai morrer com você
porque todo dia eu você e todos nós
estamos aprendendo algo novo e isso não
é sobre mim e sim sobre todas as
mulheres negras sobre todas as minorias
e sobre todas as futuras gerações que
estão por vir
propiciar elas que tenham cada vez mais
liberdade e oportunidade
e pra mim é a chave de tudo isso e fez
sentido
e justifica tudo o que eu acredito está
na frase da escritora americana audrey
lord
eu não sou livre
enquanto alguma mulher não o for mesmo
quando as correntes dela forem
diferentes das minhas
obrigado
[Aplausos]